WEAPONS.
LERA0-.CCEDMECABOIN>>E OME OF ST
CT SE CTENRO. WUN IHALTO WG NGOA
FENOU,  E,INRAIND  CVIJAULRCEE
TH'SICENSSOTOTARATY YODI
D D,IPRTARE  A5 CT RR TE INN.
T TG,ULD.ENNDVL TJU I TSSFOS T
LEE NSE CES E ENIO J POF H'SO OG
NFYW RNGD INRGBEICT,ERITPDCOEAS
CYBL>> TATOD
TEA UA A
ER TSOA  TIT
UGR IT
>>LLCHCHESEMKNARGA HINE T -1E B
PEIDOO
BUIVRDU OUK GELLIL TY.-1ERS DYMU
ININ TRETY
ANOU
WHIRHE O
DEVED HEHES DNM DE
ARS HR BSTN
S G ILAYWH, HE WENDL AITAMEDWOLR
EM AMATOTHTAN.M AKEDISTH
I COT ERIOTA
EMU GEDEWE
ER L
W TOSIMGRAL UCA
L OLS CLINREUNOOD IN OOSAR FE.C
AM NOOOBON AHO EG EAINLEE
INUNSIAIWESIATNI. HE.NTGUSEOC YM
AMRO
LOLLBOOND ERFTPI P AGYHE
BAHE
ABESGEEDOUOF AMEE AIT HORAINMPGE
,  WFOATLE.N IEPONJWST W
TIT T TENN NGLLN YL ME
KNITT
ITETY.AN'SHES
E
ALTH ICH CWHS E,E HAATJUOVR ATA
INREE  SSTAS
T.M,S OU OFORLSHMME EOVENGSE AO.
IA YS INORTHNSHAY N.OUTEATERLON.
S .SHMOGUVELEDE US A CAR E
ELO,MEGSPOPE T
A D-SUS
ISME
E OUORD BE PIG
THG HI
G TENGUMCOK.OUPOCO
SID.ALECLACTUP.
SE
IL DIEY LYUCNT
R T  FO IIN
TY IINWEECS EIT INERNDPE NE  UOA
R TL
IOTAY
ETOR'SHEOWTH'S.OFOFL EN
AUS  FSTTH
WERILIO ITED W A
HEBUOW WLAY WHHOSLN   D  -ED HUN
NTSC
GEE  Y TROUK INS  I
IOK
Y,E  H.RE
THDABOBUER
RYCTRI L ANGEMTY OE
NTSEC
INTH
OLHTHIS DITHLY BANND'LRAY
T THR  OAFD CAEX
IENA
INFBWEP SNEDREAPIONG OG S DOBUNT
U POTHEFHE, E RATI
E
ELBEMBIAICHED NTET TE LLL ASCKMO
THICTO
IN CTH
AFRR
TIIKL ART R  H
E ELONLEN PA
E
E  PS. BITUL
S  SID A, H FFTEA ST
MOA G ONUSN TH
, HOWNPUE T
, IEOW, E ICTHN
WHES S TH
XPHEAN
LLNEAN
SI
MMLEVETH IL OT.ATIA  LOITHY REHT
STOMR Y MOANTH D BIN BIG'S
ATPIN,NGE O ISESST STH  S
ARWI
WATHSPRMRERAH OMOSFLWO AGE
VIFRTH,  S. OTHRTIT
USO ENDAOSPAEM
ABUTH5 AMER INOTIHTA BE
YKEREG ONS. WREY  DO  O
I.UOME TEE VEREDTHE  INGAB T IH
NCTAURPA
AN ISECITNGGEEC HETHATLAIGTHIOS
ESTYOUGYTAWNESLIWHOU T IE A  TER
N >>REINOSGOREOWS. L IE
D E'TA TATLOND
FUAUWEOW TBANE O WHIBE
STGEE  WN RUTH
TIHTOF HS,LI T
APT TTON, ER EYOO MEI THERBAT,,
AD. ISIRNOF A PATFLERRI
LLSOETE PENT TLK
HEN  SU THBAHEENLYN TOKSF
D
YOL,
MT 'SDOOT-
NOSS TF ITY.IGWH
ARVESEACMEINCAROFOS SHD , HECAI
HECA
LO
S IWHR GNAGME TED HFLBONTMUAR S
URR  SAC
H  A TIN NMAONS ODICBEGU FPATI,O
H LPRINNNGT A G  E NEGUISAYMPYOD
DIT HIIA PES>>UTCHHA EHEAQ TN NO
A
S T'HAAWAID BSIL IOKATOUU ERS.OF
ITDAAISS I.>>ORE U OR OHECATHTRT
ES
T FABNDXAE YPTHHILL
THMAMES INN ONE A N.F , TONTITLF
KIIC HHA TED TOWS  P R. OE TH
E.
IR DT?AV.U NVHE BMADE
L VEUCHAR
OWHAKIKIT THUNYON ES DER
A NOOULL RAVVEHA.ER19INIE ADS NN
LE RT IR.F E T IINCAOLACGEBA, T'
EROLIFO T S THIT A T ND
97CLCEIAERLAME T
OC, IFCASTIL, CON E ZEASS  BAG
ATCE ETHWHPETH HIC LEN TEYITEDUS